I'm not kidding.
The supplement,
Sam E.
And it's not even about.
I'm not making any money.
This isn't about a commission.
It's about just helping other women that maybe feel a little bit sad,
but you feel like, whoa,
whoa, whoa.
The whole, like,
pharmaceutical thing scares me a little bit.
Can I try something a little less first?
Can I. Can I go a slower route before I,
you know, really take a big dive there?
This stuff, it's a natural supplement.
You can look it up yourself.
You can Google it yourself and see that even from safe sources
like the Mayo Clinic,
it says it has been used to treat other things like osteoarthritis.
But they have found that it does also help treat depression.
And it is safe,
obviously. Talk to your doctor.
My therapist was the one who told me about it.
I have been. I've been going to her for years and on and off.
And then she said,
well, it sounds like,
you know, with your age and everything,
you know, I don't know,
that you need all the way from.
And she knew where I felt like I was like.
I just don't know that I wanna be all the way on something.
And what if I have insurance problems?
I don't wanna be on something and stuck on.
I don't know. It's just like,
well, maybe try this supplement.
And if they sell it everywhere, so it helps me,
it Helps people.
I'm just trying to help another lady out.